It was June 1931 when the law finally caught
up with Al “Scarface” Capone for good.
After three years of building a case against
Capone for tax evasion, the FBI was finally
ready to arrest and try the notorious gangster.
In the October of that same year, he was found
guilty on five counts of tax evasion between
1924 and 1929, two of which were felonies.
He was sentenced to eleven years in federal
prison, plus fines.
Though Capone “grinned as though he felt
he had gotten off easily,” his prison time
ended up draining the last healthy years of
his life.
He was released in 1939 (after spending only
seven years in prison), but illness and disease
– most notably syphilis – ravaged his
mental capacity so much that in the FBI report
it said that he had “the mentality of a
twelve year old.”
He died in 1947 on Palm Island at the age
of 48.
Here’s the story of how Alphonse Gabriel
Capone became Al “Scarface” Capone.
Alphonse Capone was born January 17, 1899
in Brooklyn, a middle child in a large Italian
immigrant family.
His family moved around Brooklyn, in order
to make sure they could afford the housing.
This contributed to turning an otherwise smart
boy (when he actually was in school, he purportedly
maintained a B average, which was more of
an accomplishment then than now) into one
who regularly played hookey and was mischievous.
His legendary temper was already apparent
at 14, when he hit a teacher that he thought
was unfairly lecturing him.
He officially dropped out of school soon after,
like several of his brothers.
He took a few honest jobs – at a candy store,
pin boy at a bowling alley, and a cutter at
a book bindery – but that didn’t last
long.
At 15 or 16 years old, Al joined his first
gang, the South Brooklyn Rippers.
Quickly after, he was initiated into a more
prestigious gang, the Forty Thieves Junior
– a junior version of the notorious Five
Points Gang.
A later version of the mostly Irish gangs
of Five Points that was depicted in the 2002
film Gangs of New York, the Five Points Gang
was primarily made up of Italian-Americans
and led by Paul Kelly.
Born Paolo Antonio Vaccarelli- he changed
his name to Paul Kelly in order not to seem
so Italian- Kelly was a charmer, a tough guy,
and quite a skilled boxer.
In fact, he was such a good prize fighter
that he earned enough money to open his own
businesses – mostly brothels and gambling
houses.
His establishments were often frequented by
Tammany Hall politicians.
Soon, him and his boys were “campaigning”
for Tammany Hall candidates, making sure the
right people got elected.
In 1903, Kelly was arrested for assault and
robbery, serving nine months in jail.
Upon his release, he opened the Paul Kelly
Athletic Association, a gym or club for youngsters
to learn how to box and fight.
This is how Kelly and his cohorts recruited
the next generation of gangsters, like Meyer
Lansky, Bugsy Siegel, Frankie Yale, and Al
Capone.
It was Frankie Yale who recruited Capone to
the Five Pointers.
Six years older than Capone, Yale was known
to engage in a fight or three, most famously
when he and a buddy “cleaned out” a Coney
Island pool hall with only a pool cue and
a few billiard balls.
Besides fighting, Yale was in and out of trouble
with the law through his late teens.
But like Kelly before him and Capone after,
Yale knew the key to being a great criminal
was being a good businessman.
He got himself involved in the ice business
(yes, in a time before everyone had freezers,
ice was big business), selling “protection”
to icemen and enforcing territories.
He made enough money to open a bar in Coney
Island, he called Harvard Inn – as a play
on his own college-themed name.
He hired Capone to work as a bouncer at that
inn.
Harvard Inn was strategically placed, even
though when Yale opened it in 1917, he didn’t
know it yet.
Located in an alley between Surf and what
would become Boardwalk, Harvard Inn had exclusive
access to the water – making it one of the
first bars to serve liquor from the “coastal
rum-runners” during Prohibition (which began
three years later, in 1920).
Yale, who by 1917 was already rather successful
with the Harvard Inn, a mortuary, betting
on prizefighters, and a line of cigars, would
become extremely wealthy due to his good luck
and well-positioned bar.
Being a bouncer at Harvard Inn required a
“certain finesse,” according to Robert
Schoenberg’s book Mr. Capone.
They had to do it with tact and authority,
but not too much that the customer didn’t
want to come back.
Capone was quite good and besides becoming
his bouncer, Capone became Yale’s pupil.
Yale considered himself a businessman first,
not a thug or a criminal.
Sure, he extorted, “protected,” and racketed,
but that was just part of business.
If he needed someone beat up or even killed,
he would never do it himself – he would
hire someone.
In Capone’s early days in the industry,
he often played this role, in addition to
being a bouncer.
When Capone became the boss, he adhered to
this strategy as well.
Yale was also quite brutal, with the legend
being that he beat his own 16 year old kid
brother so badly for lying to him that his
brother had to go to the hospital.
Capone also picked up on this as well.
New York City was experiencing a heatwave
in early August of 1917.
To escape the heat, many came to Coney Island
to play in the water and sleep on the cool
beach at night.
For this reason, it was as crowded as Coney
Island had ever been.
And Harvard Inn, due to its location, fans
and cold drinks, was packed every day of this
heat wave.
This brings us to how Al Capone got his famous
scars.
On one particular day during this time, a
small stocky “hood” named Frank Galluccio
sauntered into the bar with his date, Maria
Tanzo, on one arm and his younger sister,
Lena, on another.
Despite the crowds, Capone, who was 18 at
the time, honed in on Lena.
Watching from afar, he finally got up the
nerve to talk to her, asking her to take a
walk with him along the beach.
She supposedly said no and Capone walked away,
but that didn’t stop him from continuing
to watch her.
A little later, he supposedly asked her again
for that walk.
Lena, none too please, informed her brother
of this annoying guy.
She them told him that he was embarrassing
her, but asked Frank to make him stop “in
a nice way.”
Galluccio took action, fully aware the situation
could escalate.
As such, he told his female counterparts to
meet him outside.
Before they could reach the door, Capone reportedly
stepped in and told Lena loudly, “I’ll
tell you one thing, you got a nice a** honey
and I mean that as a compliment.”
Hearing this, Galluccio demanded an apology
from Capone for the remark.
Capone wasn’t having it, telling Galluccio
he was only joking around.
This is when the situation got dicey.
You see, Galluccio was only five foot six
and slight of build and was now attempting
to defend his sister’s honor by going toe
to toe with the five foot eleven, very beefy
Capone.
Being at something of a disadvantage physically,
Galluccio decided to escalate the situation
beyond fists and pulled out his knife, slashing
at Capone, and managing to get in three cuts
to Capone’s face and upper neck before Capone
went down.
With Capone on the ground in a pool of blood,
Galluccio ran out of the Harvard Inn.
At this point, Capone was rushed to Coney
Island Hospital where he received eighty stitches
and was told he’d wear the scars forever.
Galluccio, knowing what he had done and who
he’d done it to, feared for his life.
This came to a head when Frankie Yale demanded
a meeting with both Capone and Galluccio at
the Harvard Inn.
Sitting them both down, Yale turned Capone’s
head to show Galluccio the giant scars that
would be tattooed on Capone forever, ultimately
earning him the nickname “Scarface.”
Galluccio, thinking this was the end of his
life, tried to plead his case.
But Yale never had any intention of hurting
or killing Galluccio.
He was a businessman and simply wanted to
profit from this unfortunate scenario.
He ordered that Galluccio pay Capone $1,500
for his trouble (about $27,000 today).
In return, Capone had to promise never to
retaliate.
To top it off, Yale would lend Galluccio the
money, making Galluccio indebted to Yale and
earning interest to boot.
Galluccio and Capone both agreed to this and
the matter was settled.
Throughout his life, Capone would usually
claim his scars were acquired fighting in
France during World War I.
He rarely owned up to the fact that his nickname
came from a bar fight when a smaller man slashed
his face for making rude comments to
his sister.